imagine a world where instead of raining
water it rains diamonds well even in a
wild list of imaginations it's very
difficult to imagine isn't it but what
if I told you that this phenomenon
happens somewhere within our own solar
system itself we are not so lucky that
it happens on the Earth but scientists
believe that in Uranus and Neptune this
phenomenon is very possible to occur do
you know why because the atmospheric
pressure is so high in Uranus and
Neptune that carbon might in fact get
condensed to form diamonds and rain in
the atmosphere yes that's right but not
just diamonds it also Reigns sulfuric
acid on Venus so if it falls on your
skin if you were to be there by any
chance then your skin would corrode so
my advice would be don't go and enjoy
the rainfall meals for more such
fascinating videos subscribe to our
Channel